we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here is a
just vicious vicious attack on the david
pakman show
from a trump supporter take away what
you need to do is stick your tail
between your legs and cower down and
sneak off like a dog got that like a dog
I'm a little weasel thank you all right
that's right I don't know how the
program will ever survive that so we
won't even attempt to fight back against
this type of just um you know brilliant
and devastating political critique Jeff
Sessions is announcing a run for the
Senate we are going to discuss that on
today's bonus show Italy is going to
become the first country to make
learning about climate change compulsory
for school students and Las Vegas
continues to criminalize poverty and
homelessness adopting a new ban which
prohibits sleeping camping on streets
and sidewalks we there's actually a lot
to say about this and as someone who
goes to Vegas twice a year I have some
thoughts about it so we will be
discussing that in detail on today's
bonus show what is the bonus or the
bonus show is another it's an additional
show that we do every day we've got the
broadcast show which we are rapidly
approaching the conclusion of for today
and then we've got the bonus show if you
want to access the bonus show become a
member at join pakman.com or become a
patron at patreon.com slash david pakman
show and at least the $5 a month level
and that will get you instant access to
the bonus show I will speak to you then